it's fascinating to see masses of people
walking some folks considered watch them
for hours the crowd of people numbers
almost 50,000 all marching through the
Dutch city of Nijmegen voluntarily as
much as 55 kilometers a day the footwear
will decide and of course the stamina
marching through Holland and for days I
will join and walk the route part of it
anyway
the temperatures are hovering just under
35 degrees Celsius that tends to beg the
question why are these people doing it
you lose some weight that's all yes why
are you here I don't know I took a
reading break I'm reading and walking
now it's good to save time what's the
reason for you to take part to take part
just for the fun I want to walk it takes
a dose of willpower as well but not so
much on the first 250 meters it's the
100th time the masses have gone for this
collective walk a colorful International
Festival for pedestrians in good shape
and for a number of professionals
this is how the Swedish troops celebrate
every stage they complete the origin of
the walk of the world is in fact
military the Dutch Armed Forces
introduced the practice over a century
ago as fitness training for their troops
now soldiers from more than 60 countries
join in
there are no power blocks or political
alliances here military personnel from
the world over walk side-by-side we're
all here from different countries but
we're all doing the same event and we're
cheering on the same people and I mean
it means a lot and we'll definitely be
spreading the word to tell more people
about it because a lot of people back in
the states they'll know about it
the soldiers try to march in time but
for most others it's a matter of just
completing every stage especially toward
late evening
here military personnel and civilians
fraternize openly the world becomes a
village in the best sense
that will be together with friends and
meet new people around and this is an
option to do it also okay IML box
different places in the world so this is
the biggest one of all of them so it's a
good opportunity to meet other people
also I want to exercise that's the basic
idea behind the walk as an exhibition
along the way explains the aim of
promoting understanding among nations
through hiking is relatively new in 1909
the motives were strictly athletic in
nature the goal was to have a lot of
people walk and exercise in a healthy
way so not like the Tour de France or a
marathon that is really exhausting and
very difficult effort but just a normal
workout for a lot of people world
campground
there are hikers from all over but some
of them are nursing injuries from the
road terrible I stumbled too early in
the morning just after two start against
a student who passed out of drinks no
ice packs beer and rest little walk
anymore no more walking anymore
an excellent idea time to check out the
field kitchen yes I'm the Haitian chef
today and tomorrow my I'm an Italian
chef so you you're welcome to come back
and if you want to join for dinner
why not okay okay at this festival of
Nations even an exhausted reporter can
find a place to rest his weary head time
for a short break see you in about 12
hours